when I thought about this morning now I
decided I would be a little personal in
the beginning then talk a little bit
about the sort of arts in my world at
MIT and then a little bit about where
it's going and the personal part isn't
really to talk about me as much as to
maybe put some of the attitudes in
context when I was in first grade I
didn't think my first grade teacher was
doing a good job so what I did is I made
an appointment with the headmaster I got
the appointment I sat in the office
waiting with a few other be my feet
didn't even hit the ground I got my
appointment I explained to the
headmaster mr. Hubbell why I thought the
first grade teacher wasn't very good and
he thanked me and that was the beginning
of my academic career I sort of behaved
like that for the rest of my life and
sort of in keeping with that I did
school half in the United States half in
Europe and before coming to MIT my last
two years were at an American prep
school in Connecticut where they did
sports they play football they played
hunt they I thought sports was too
stupid to participate in so what do I do
I went to the headmaster and I said to
the headmaster you know I want to do art
during all the sports periods and he
said Wow nobody's ever suggested that of
course you can and so I did no sports
and every afternoon when everybody else
was doing this stupid stop or at least
what I thought was pretty stupid I was
in the art studio doing art so that was
kind of phase two of kind of going to
the headmaster and sort of trying to get
the rules changed then I went back to
the same person slightly longer story I
had always done well I'd won all the art
prizes there were to win in weather
it was you know primary school middle
school high school but I made a mistake
of getting an 800 on my SAT my math exam
and I didn't quite know what to do and
MIT had given the early acceptance
probably because of the 800 and I went
to the same headmaster and I said you
know I do well seemingly in math and
I've always loved art what I should do
is go study architecture and he said
something so profound it went right over
my head he said I think he called me
Nicky
because I was at that stage of life for
people called me Nicky said Nicky um I
like grey suits and I like pinstripe
suits but I don't like grey pinstripe
suits that went right over me and I even
know I even found a pinstripe suit this
morning and I thought I'd wear the
pinstripe suit I didn't create I went to
architecture school and I came to MIT
and it took me about three years to
realize that architecture for me was if
you will a gray pinstripe suit but
computers were the intersection of art
and mathematics and technology so when I
came as a freshman in 1961 most people
in this room weren't born President
Kennedy was the president it was
extraordinary year for me because coming
to MIT was quite extraordinary Kepesh
who became my advisor and my professor
and for those of you don't know he was
sort of the last surviving Bauhaus sort
of figure he had been brought to MIT in
1948 from Chicago where he was with
moholy-nagy before moholy-nagy died he
came here partly because Gropius was at
Harvard and he started doing he was a
professor in the School of Architecture
and planning and did many great things
try I won't accept I viewed it as an
influence I found in a person somebody
who really understood at least what I
thought was the future and then I caught
a bug and the bug was computer
programming I learned how to compute a
program pretty early on and loved doing
it so much I worked on a program here
excuse this terrible slide but this
slide was a display now we're talking
1963 864 in this you know just the
concept of displays were pretty and this
was a computer program that routed
automobiles from a given point to
another given point and you type the
coordinates in there were a thousand
automobiles in the system and it would
go to the pickup point and drop you at
the destination the acronym was cars
stood for computer-aided routing system
and welcome to Ober 63-64 and so I I
just couldn't get over it I couldn't
program enough and Marcia SAFTA steps
into the world now mushers 1/2 day it's
not only alive today he's actually very
young because unlike architects he was
23 24 at the time I was 18 or 19
whatever he had done habitat for the
World's Fair in Montreal in 67 and that
project completely changed at least the
MIT Department of Architecture I was
working on my thesis and so on and we're
all rushing out to buy sugar cubes to
build our models and all the models were
little mini habitats and of course then
when I went to to sort of what am I
going to do after graduating I figured
well instead of trying to be an
architect why not build the tools for
architects you'd have a bigger influence
maybe your ego isn't satisfied quite the
same way
if you could make the tools that the
architects use that would have a bigger
more global impact and guess what I
build a system that does habitat and
this is again old very old technology
very you know back here on campus and
just across the street at Tech square
that it just been built and it became
again more of an obsession than than
anything I just couldn't stop writing
computer programs and doing this sort of
stuff until we got invited to do
something at the Jewish Museum in New
York for an exhibit called software and
here we just went nuts because we
decided as the display what we would do
is we would have a robot build a habitat
basically with these blocks and you can
sort of imagine the gantry moving and
and building a little a little sort of
world of blocks and it was inhabited by
gerbils and you can see a few in the
foreground and the gerbils were put in
the box during the show and as the
gerbils ran around and moved the blocks
if the block was just slightly ajar the
program would straighten it if it was
substantially ajar get this it was
assumed to be purposeful and so the
robot would put it in the new place but
sort of straightened out so if you went
back to the exhibit you would see a sort
of mini habitat that was changing
because it was changing there are enough
purposeful events over the full day well
there are a couple of things that happen
you know
one is dribbles get tired okay so that
didn't we work for about an hour and the
other is that we had teams of gerbils we
had teams that would come out in a B C
and D team and it was again it was my
first experience doing something
computational relatively technical in
the context of a museum
we're the viewer if they the viewer
couldn't understand it it could be
called art and whether it was art
whether it was not art actually didn't
matter so as we went forward we're
building our little group in the
architecture department Phil mentioned
we did things like invent touch
sensitive displays decided that we would
try and build rooms that were computers
that you would live in the computer and
it was again for its day it had a
floor-to-ceiling display shown I think
in the next slide barely you know a
Florida ceiling display in 1973 we're
now at 73 74 was unheard of because the
way you made a floor-to-ceiling display
is by taking a piece of glass that is
rear projection glass and a 12-foot
piece of glass has to come on a special
truck and then having a huge projector
in the back which in the days cost two
hundred and fifty thousand dollars to
project that particular image and it was
funded by the Department of Defense as
very advanced human-computer interface
but allowed us to again look at the
world through interface design until I
meet this guy now coincidences play
roles that you could you look back on
life and you say to yourself why wasn't
that something it turns out that the
president's office at MIT was more or
less in a direct line with my lab if he
wanted to go to his chauffeur mr. Tibbs
I don't know if other presidents have
had chauffeurs but mr. Tibbs was his
full-time chauffer parked at the bottom
of the elevator where my lab was at the
top and as you can guess from just a
couple of pictures I've shown it was a
very photogenic lab I mean it had
like you saw you could go in you could
wear the stuff sit down the chair became
interactive so what did Jerry do most
days before lunch maybe three times a
week he would walk through the lab with
these really interesting people and once
the president's done that 20 times 40
times 60 times a hundred times you kind
of get to know each other and he told me
something they're two separate stories
here think of this as story a he said
Nicholas I am going to retire as
president but I am NOT going to become
chairman because Howard Johnson who was
then the chairman was actually younger
and doing pretty good stuff eat I don't
want to displace Howard I want to go
back and work in a lab but there's no
lab I gots no lab for me to work in and
I said Jerry I'll build you a lab and
that's basically what happened now
something else happened which is maybe
not story B yet but it's just a
coincidence
in the department of architecture there
were it was the recipient if you will or
the holding entity for the arts
activities at MIT which were not just
kept assure center for advanced visual
studies which was getting going on but
minor White was doing photography you
had even though computer music wasn't in
our department it was in our degree
program and you had computer animation
you had graphic design and those groups
had students what degree would the
students get and how could you attract
the students at undergraduate or
graduate level and so I became
accidentally
because I'm not good at this stuff or
particularly like academic
administration I became the head of
department for all the peripheral people
if you will ran the degree program and
we became literally assembled II hope
you see when we decided to build the
Media Lab a few people I have them here
very active Rikki Leacock was a was a
filmmaker running the film video program
had come to MIT Jerry Wiesner brought
him here in I think it was 68 69 partly
because of the unrest on campus Seymour
Papert who recently died was a
mathematician had worked with Piaget and
he was in in a group that no longer
exists and I went to see the then
Provost talk about having Provost under
your belt I've had them all and I went
to see this Provost and I said you know
I want to include Seymour Papert in this
new media lab he said bless your heart
just want to get rid of these people
Marvin Minsky was pretty disaffected by
the AI lab he went to get out said
Marvin join us so Marvin Seymour Rickey
and then one more Muriel Muriel was at
the MIT press and is most identified
with that as a piece of her work so
those were the founding people and the
settled if you see aspect of it was very
important partly because while we were
doing research call it the more
technical side we were printing money
and MIT is not going to disrupt the
Golden Goose while you're making golden
eggs so you could be the center of the
IPC you could do this crazy stuff as
long as you were self-supporting and and
we were but when we decided to build
lab MIT said something very appropriate
they said if you and Jerry Wiesner are
going to do this which took raising I
think was 40 million dollars which I
used to think of as a lot of money but
40 million dollars don't go back to our
donors don't go back to old friends
don't go to Texas Instruments don't go
to you know the people who have been
supporting us make new friends well new
friends came from three places and God
we spent a lot of time in those three
places Hollywood nobody at MIT had ever
gone to Hollywood
there isn't a movie studio that didn't
fund the Media Lab I could tell you
stories the only actually funny story
was that I rage had breakfast with
Robert Redford to get 20th Century Fox
to fund us and what he does at breakfast
is he gets Jerry Wiesner to fund him per
million dollars from the MacArthur
Foundation I said Wow Jerry that
breakfast would just turned out exactly
the upside down we were supposed to get
money from them not you give him hey ray
Hollywood was one personal computers by
definition was one because it didn't
exist before so Steve Jobs was very
active he was he participated and in
fact he gave us half a million dollars
when he could ill afford it check the
actually a paper check I remember taking
it and the third was Japan Japan was
important because when Jerry Wiesner was
President Kennedy's science advisor
President Kennedy had sent him to Japan
to help the Japanese rebuild their
industries well flash forward 20 years
and we're back there guess what the
people who Jerry talked to were suddenly
the CEOs and the Chairman's of those
companies so boom that was the third
group and that put us put us into
business we built the building I'll tell
you hundreds of stories about the
building and the
thesis was and I suspect while people
may not say it the same way it's that
the creative users are the inventors .
if you look at the history of
photography by and large it was invented
by photographers somebody wanted faster
speed
somebody wanted color somebody wanted
motion television was the exact opposite
television was invented by engineers who
then threw it over the wall and told
people to use it my comment to Jerry and
to the corporation is that computers
will be like photography and that the
creative users in the future are going
to invent it that's the entire thesis of
the lab and at the time the medium is
not the message which was kind of wild
because because but the medium is a
message God was getting an awful lot of
attention and was on people's lips
though they didn't really think about
what does it mean to be digital and bits
are bits the medium is not the message
ok the message is the message because
it's actually embodied in some
representation that then can be put on a
screen or then be put out and sound or
whatever you can't experience bit bits
are not experienced about they have no
size shape color etc etc so but misfits
come along now we're in business we were
hiring faculty and we start finding
people around the world who and I happen
I just I could pick many people I decide
I'll just pick for Japanese and the
first one is this young man who was
working at NTT and they were so
embarrassed by his work they bore let's
put him in a closet and the first time I
went to visit they say I know you don't
want to go down there you want to see
that next time I said hey
we do and when I met Hiroshi Ishii I
said Hiroshi
come out of the closet come to MIT and
he did and he's had a good 20 plus year
history John my ADA studied electrical
engineering at MIT he was in the ph.d
program and he hated his six-foot-seven
Germanic heel clicking advisor who was
telling him to do this this and this I
said John drop out he did his parents
could have killed me because they'd
worked their whole life for John to go
to college and Here I am advising him to
drop out he drops out he goes to Japan
because he hadn't been - parents are
both Japanese but he's born here he
finds his identity in Japan he gets a
PhD in Japan and then sadly Muriel
Cooper whom I showed you earlier dies
very young unexpected and we hire
replacement faculty do a massive search
and Shawn my ADA comes up and comes back
and joins the faculty so it took about
ten years for the parents to love me
again and he came as a faculty member
and did a wonderful job until he went on
to be the president of RISD this is
newer news spoot Nikko joined us quite
recently from the Royal College of art
that had done her her on her master's
work at Imperial College and and Neri is
really sort of what this whole meetings
about and I don't know if she's
participating but I'm sure her work will
be cited now why did the Media Lab
succeed that you can judge whether it
succeeded I'm not trying to say you know
looking succeeded didn't succeed because
of me it succeeded because of a little
twist a little twist of fate that I
don't know if I was just on my feet or
Jerry Wiesner or Howard Johnson Howard
Johnson was the chairman of the board of
MIT and I think it's fair to say that
most people on the board many faculty
thought
Jerry Wiesner was wasting his time with
Nicholas Negroponte and that even worse
it was an opportunity cost because Jerry
could raise money he could sell the
Eskimo icebergs that he was just such a
good fundraiser isn't it a shame he's
not doing it for something else well as
it got a little bit of momentum and as
Phil and Marty and others in the MIT
administration while you might not say
it the way I'm going to say it MIT
really has to think of it as two axes
one are the academic departments and the
others of the labs and I'm being a
little simplistic but let me call them
church and state the academic
departments admit the students aboard
the degrees hire the faculty bring up
the ten-year cases and so on and so
forth and in rough terms the labs have
contracts and money in space and higher
up pay for Ras and do the sort of that
kind of stuff and I said Howard at the
time I said you know I think it would be
really good if we were both a lab and an
academic department not as a power-play
but because we wanted to admit students
who had strong arts backgrounds who
would have never gotten in that Monday
we want to hire faculty who were doing
things that again weren't part of it
also what self-respecting artist at the
time would apply or think they could get
heard so we felt we really had to have
that church and state license and and it
works I think it worked quite quite
successfully because of that one fluke
and get the correct mover it never
happened before and I don't think it's
happening that doesn't mean it's not
happened because people hate it and then
as as Phil mentioned we did a search
about six years ago we were doing a
search for a new director
for the Media Lab and I couldn't one of
the rules of MIT and I think it happens
a lot of places you can't be on the
search of your successor you can't be on
the search committee and so I wasn't on
my immediate successor but but he had
the good judgment to leave after five
years and I could be on the search
committee of his successor which is why
Phil and I and a few others and this
name pops
Joey Ito now the search committee
started in September maybe even late
August and somebody says around the
table you may I don't believe I'm being
revisionist but you can correct me says
does anybody in the room know Joey Ito
because his name had come up and I said
yes I do I know and Joey Ito hadn't
graduated from college he was a dropout
of Chicago it was a dropout at tuft disc
jockey each time he was a dropout wet
off to Japan did was quite well-known
and successful in the internet world of
Japan and they said look if you know him
could you please send him an email
thanking him for applying but telling
him in some kind way that he doesn't
qualify
so I write Joey a note I say Joey thank
you for applying I forget exactly how I
phrased it it said but you know you you
know you're really pushing the limits
we've you don't qualify you know you
don't even have an undergraduate degree
you know this is impossible and and look
forward to seeing you wherever we meet
next September October November December
January February March March this
committee comes up empty and the
committee looks at itself says why don't
we revisit the people who turned us down
and whom we turn down sometimes people
turn you down because a two-body problem
and the husband doesn't want to move or
or the weather or some reasons that you
maybe could go back and push on
and then we could relook at the ones
that we didn't consider and book Joey's
name pops up again I forget if people
for God or just you know pushing I they
say well you know who knows and I know
I'm could you send him an email and ask
him if he's interested and I sent him
three words where are you and I got an
instant answer in one word Bahamas and
then I said something like get your ass
up to MIT tomorrow or something like
that he was here two days later he
walked in as far as I'm concerned
probably Phil - he got the job he just
was just such a perfect thing then one
has to market it and sell it and push it
through the administration and I have to
tell you and so far as the media labs my
baby giving it to him it is really a
wonderful wonderful change so in the two
minutes that are left where we headed in
the future and I have two slides of this
and one more if I have to say a buzzword
biotech is the new digital it'll happen
in many places not just going to happen
at the Media Lab it's going to happen
mit is very much a place for that sort
of thing to happen and why is it
happening it's happening because a
Fineman at least his paper was the first
one I read that as we get smaller and
smaller and this is the this is the
zinger this is something that you just
got a sleep on just reading it as I grew
up with the working assumption and I'll
use an old-fashioned politically
incorrect term the man-made world and
the natural world
were orthogonal and that good
architecture for example was the skill
and art of putting things in nature in
such a way that enhanced nature that
didn't disrupt it or or maybe
provided things that that weren't there
but cetera you could you can imagine
that there would be the symbiosis of
this artificial world and this natural
world and suddenly going forward from
sort of this point on they're the same
they're not different and suddenly we
can actually not just be informed by
nature we can actually do things and in
some cases better than nature so it's a
very complex you know think about and
there's so many ramifications but that's
in my opinion is what going to govern
the next decade of thought at places
like the Media Lab and I think in places
like MIT is that that that world is
coming together so with that mark thank
you very remarkable beer